we've got a voicemail number it's two
one nine two david p you can call
anytime
and today's voicemail caller raises a
really important issue and it's one
we've been talking about and not
surprisingly i I apologize I know it's
like a broken record but it leads back
to why why we've got a vote in November
take a listen to this hey David it's
Tanner from Las Vegas I've just been
wondering why there's so many of these
Trump supporters seem to not have their
own best interests in mind like it kind
of seems like they just want Trump to be
the best and not fail at all at any cost
even if they're wrong right uh thanks
okay there is not one answer to the
question the question is a really good
one we asked it during the Tea Party
movement of 2010 we're asking it now why
do all these right-wing voters vote
against their own best interests there
are those on the right who want to
praise this by saying you know what the
reason right-wing voters support
policies that aren't obviously in their
own best interests is because they want
to do the right thing over what's good
for them personally they're not selfish
they are really empathetic and
sympathetic people and to that I would
say there is no evidence whatsoever that
that's actually the case there's a few
reasons well people why people vote
against their own best interest when it
comes to economic stuff like low taxes
on the rich or whatever else very often
people who are not actually going to
benefit from those policies support
those policies because they believe that
they have a good shot at one day
benefiting from those policies now of
course it's possible that they would
maybe someday be rich enough to benefit
from these policies statistically though
almost none of them will there's very
low income mobility in the United States
and aside from of course cases of
celebrities and athletes and people who
hit it big without going to college
statistically most of them will never
actually benefit and they just misjudge
the likelihood that they will one day
actually benefit from those policies
then there has been a really successful
framing effort by the right to frame a
lot of these issues as moral issues so
even though the tea partiers by and
large weren't going to benefit from
cuts for the rich they've been
bamboozled by the very strong and well
put together messaging machine of the
right to believe that they are on the
right moral side if they have religious
beliefs the right has been very good at
linking supply side economic policy to
being Jesus like in some way can you
imagine right when what we know of Jesus
if he existed was that he was more
socialistic if anything that then
capitalistic so there's a number of
different reasons why people on the
right and end up either getting tricked
or confused into supporting policies
that aren't good for them and there's
not a one-size-fits-all answer to that
yeah here's another theory that it
starts with the social issues like these
people are against abortion they're
against gay rights yeah and then just
the way politics is it becomes a whole
grab bag because they're opposed to
those two issues and they also have to
be skeptical of climate change they also
have to be a court up of taxes for tax
cuts for the rich and you know opposed
to welfare programs just how it happened
it becomes like a package of positions
basically and it may not actually be and
we know actually that with more
religious voters their entry point into
voting Republican is heavily based on
their religiosity and then it just kind
of goes with with the other stuff as Pat
is pointing out on the bonus show today
Trump advisor Stephen Miller threw out
$80 worth of sushi to protest a
protester the Trump administration is
yet again attacking Obama care we talked
about Trump's obsessions attacking Obama
care is another one and the UK foreign
secretary Boris Johnson has resigned
over the brexit plan and things are
getting pretty hectic in British
Parliament we're going to talk about
that and much much more get access to
the bonus show and support the program
by signing up for membership at wwlp.com
or by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show